president Donald Trump has regularly
boasted of his crew Israel record he did
it again as he signed a new executive
order this time aimed at fighting what
the White House sees as a growing
problem of anti-semitism on university
campuses across the u.s. this is our
message to universities if you want to
accept the tremendous amount of federal
dollars that you get every year you must
reject anti-semitism it's very simple
essentially the order extends part of
the 1964 Civil Rights Act it allowed the
Department of Education to withhold
federal funding from any college that
discriminates on the grounds of race
color or national origin that now is
extended to a religion and critics say
that effectively suggests Jews are
people who share the same race or
collective national origin the new order
could significantly impact the BDS
movement it urges a boycott divestment
and sanctions campaign against the
Israeli government for its treatment of
Palestinians living in the region some
have claimed BDS is anti-semitic while
supporters say it's not targeting a
religion but political action but as the
group has grown on American campuses
it's been accused of creating a hostile
climate for Jewish students by
conflating include the criticism of
Israel and make it equal to you know
anti-semitism they're trying to censor
any free debate here in the US when it
comes to this really apart policies
Donald Trump is aggressively backed as
real since taking office he moved the US
Embassy to Jerusalem in the face of
international opposition and recognized
the Golan Heights territory seized from
Syria as part of Israel but he's been
accused of making anti-semitic remarks
and defending neo-nazis who chanted
anti-jewish slogans he was criticized
for comments made in a speech to Jewish
groups in Florida at the weekend for
reinforcing Jewish stereotypes a lot of
you are in the real estate business
because I know you very well
your brutal killers not nice people at
all but you have to vote for me yep no
choice you're not gonna vote for
Pocahontas I can tell you
many Jewish groups have praised the
president's action US Congress tried to
take a similar action to the executive
order even with bipartisan support it
stalled Donald Trump smooth breaks that
logjam Alan Fisher al Jazeera Washington
let's week tom arban dodd he's the
deputy director of the arab-american
Institute he's joining us from
Washington thanks for joining us on the
al Jazeera news hour to you what is this
executive order really about is it about
anti-semitism and and anti
discrimination or is it about trying to
suppress Palestinian advocacy on college
campuses as some people say it is it is
definitely about suppressing
pro-palestine advocacy on college
campuses under under the guise of
fighting anti-semitism but we know it's
not about anti-semitism for multiple
reasons including the fact that Donald
Trump himself is a huge contributor to
the problem of anti-semitism in this
country including the clip that you
played earlier and also suggesting that
American Jews who do not vote for him
are somehow disloyal he's been a huge
part of the problem and ultimately what
this executive order is about its
expands the definition of anti-semitism
to include criticism of Israel and the
risk here is that students on college
campuses who are simply engaged in
pro-palestine advocacy for human rights
could get into serious trouble simply
because their criticism of Israel can
now be construed as anti-semitism this
by the way is blatantly unconstitutional
it's a violation of free speech which is
one of the most fundamentally cherished
values in American life so this has been
an absolute disaster and I think that
it's only a matter of time before this
is challenged and rescinded yeah we'll
talk about how it can be challenged in a
moment but does it actually do anything
to address the issue of anti-semitism
which we know is on the rise in the
United States so there's no question
about the fact that anti-semitism is on
the rise and it is a growing problem and
in fact bigotry in many forms is rising
in the current political climate that
this president has contributed to but
this the only changed that this
executive order makes is specifically
that expansion of definition to include
criticism of Israel so harassment of
American Jewish students on college
campuses was already a violation of
title six of under civil rights the
civil rights office so
there's nothing new on that particular
front this is clearly just an attempt to
pander to the pro-israel base that this
president feels accountable to he's
surrounded by Jared Kushner and David
Friedman and really really right-wing
pro-israel Hawks and they have a pretty
much a base in this country that he's
trying to appeal to as a way to gin up
political frustration and see if he can
build up some support leading up to the
next election that's what this is
ultimately about and in the process the
Constitution of the u.s. is being
undermined by this president in an
effort to pander to these forces and
back on the issue of how this can be
challenged which you brought up a moment
ago how do you see that process playing
out how can it be challenged and
overturned so it's it's important to
note that this is not a new effort this
has already been an ongoing effort
including under the Obama administration
this has been litigated where there were
multiple complaints brought to the Civil
Rights office of the Department of
Education trying to punish palette
students who hold pro-palestine activism
on college campuses and the civil rights
office under the Obama administration
simply rejected those efforts and
insisted that what is taking place is
simply free political speech
unfortunately one of the people who was
bringing those cases has now been put in
charge of the Civil Rights office under
the trump administration his name is Ken
Marcus which is a huge part of the
problem but you have I think you're
going to see that the entire civil
rights advocacy organizations in the
u.s. activated including organizations
like the American Civil Liberties Union
which is a huge organization that is
devoted to civil rights and it does not
take any positions on the
israeli-palestinian conflict in
particular however it has been very
outspoken against efforts to expand the
definition of anti-semitism and all that
has happened here is that where these
efforts have failed through Congress
before through legislation like the so
called anti-semitism awareness Act these
groups that are pushing for this agenda
have now found an ally in President
Trump to impose by decree that opinion
on the country in a way that has not you
know because they have not been able to
achieve it in any other way and it's
only a matter of time before that falls
apart all right all my words are we
thank you for joining us from Washington